(bright signature chime)
So we're going to continue our conversations
this afternoon as we look at STI, vaginitis, and vaginosis.
Nothing to disclose here still,
and of course this is a saga
that is continuing to grow in the United States.
We've had consecutive years of increased reporting
of chlamydia, gonorrhea, and syphilis.
We've had a 71% rise in syphilis since 2014,
a 63% rise in gonorrhea, and a 19% rise
in the number one reported sexually transmitted infection,
which is chlamydia.
The most common STI in the US is HPV.
Remember, there are over 200 HPV types.
Now, the USPSTF way back in 2020 recommends
behavioral counseling for all sexually active adolescents
and for adults who are at increased risk.
In particularly, those at increased risk
are multiple sexual partners.
And if you do not consistently use condoms,
and you've had an STI in the past six months.
Now there are counseling looked at anywhere
from 30 minutes to two hours.
You are not gonna have those resources in your practice.
However, most successful approaches will use
basic information looking at transmission, use of condoms,
and then communication about safe sex.
Here's our first case, a 22-year-old G0 woman
presents for an annual well-woman evaluation,
she complains of vaginal discharge for two days.
No lesions on the vulva of the vagina,
but the cervix appears red and almost strawberry texture.
There's yellowish, yellow malodorous leukorrhea,
but no notable pus at the os.
Bimanual, there's this cervical tenderness and fullness.
The exam is limited due the patient's size.
Here's our question.
Of the following, which is the most likely diagnosis?
HSV, trichomoniasis, candida, or bacterial vaginosis?
Okay, so trichomoniasis is the most common here
in terms of the symptoms which are presented to us.
Because you get a malodorous discharge,
you can see this kind of irritation.
They can be somewhat tender,
but typically it's a non-specific pelvic pain.
With HSV, of course it's a painful ulceration,
Candida, thick, itchy.
Remember, BV is not a STI,
it is a shift or overgrowth in the bacterial flora.
They can get a malodorous discharge,
you can see itching, but you will not see any pain.
Now let's take a look at this question.
According to the CDC, which one of the following
is the recommended regimen for
trichomonas vaginal infection treatment in women?
Metrogel, Metronidazole, Metronidazole, or Tinidazole?
Okay, so the correct answer now is Metronidazole
500 BID for seven days.
It used to be two grams,
but now it's 500 BID for seven days.
So in women we use the BID dosing for seven days,
men, you can still use the two gram single dose.
If there is a resistance, very uncommon,
this is where you would use the two gram single dose.
Less efficacious is using the local preparation.
And since this is an STI, you should treat the partner.
Now what about if there's a treatment failure?
So they've completed the seven days
and she has not been re-exposed,
then you should be re-treated with metronidazole
two grams once daily for seven days
if there's been no re-exposure.
If she's been re-exposed,
then you would use the same regimen once again.
'Cause the patient says, listen, I took my seven days,
and I have not been back with him.
Okay.
Then we repeat the same regimen.
If no, or excuse me, you would use the two grams,
because she said no re-exposure.
But if she's been re-exposed,
oh I know, but he said he loved me and-
(audience laughing)
You know what happened, then I'm like,
I know what happened then.
Okay, men, if it's persistent, meaning no re-exposure,
you retreat with a single two gram dose.
If they've not been re-exposed,
then you now treat them with 500 milligrams
two times per day for seven days.
Now what about if you are metronidazole sensitive?
You can't tolerate it.
The recommendation is to desensitize.
The optimal treatment, if you can't do that,
is something called paromomycin,
which is not even available in the US,
or you can use boric acid, okay?
But typically you're going to need to desensitize them.
Now, very high rates of reinfection here,
so the CDC says, women who have been treated should be,
undergo, I should say, a repeat evaluation for infection
in three months.
Because there are very high rates of reinfection.
So if they've been treated and symptoms resolved,
they should have a test for reinfection in three months.
In pregnancy, Metronidazole is used
in each of the trimesters, it doesn't matter.
You can use it if you're breastfeeding.
What you can't use is Tinidazole if you're breastfeeding.
So you wanna avoid that in pregnant women.
And if you're breastfeeding, you have to delay breastfeeding
for 72 hours after a single two gram dose.
BV, here are the current clinical criteria,
you need three of the four, bless you.
Discharge, high pH, clue cells and a Whiff test.
Now, the most sensitive and specific of the clue cells,
the Whiff test, you're looking for volatilized amines
when you apply KOH.
Be careful, semen will do the same exact thing.
However, you typically will be able to notice the difference
between a trick and semen on your specimen.
Now this is not just an annoyance element.
It's associated with premature rupture membranes,
preterm delivery, vaginitis, you name it.
The treatment, here it's Metronidazole BID
for seven days as well.
Alternatively, you use clindamycin.
If it's recurrent, three or more episodes in 12 months,
here you're going to use a local prep,
five grams in the vagina, two times per week
for four to six months.
This is a very difficult challenge.
Now what about probiotics?
Eat yogurt, vaginal suppositories.
So the patient can put yogurt in a gel cap
and make their own vaginal suppository,
it's like a little Pinterest project.
(audience laughing)
You need to remind them though,
they have to use plain yogurt, no fruit-based yogurt,
all that kind of stuff, that causes a problem.
So it's easy just to have them eat it daily for two months.
For BV, helpful, candidiasis, no help,
there's no adverse effects associated with it, okay?
Next question.
39-year-old diabetic female, hemoglobin A1c is 11.4,
feeling good now, down to 11.4.
First time it's registered in years.
Presents to the office with an eight day history
of thick white vaginal discharge and vulvar itching.
She tried a seven day over the counter treatment,
but amidst to only completing five days.
On exam, you find extensive vulvar erythema,
excoriation edema, there's a thick curd-like white discharge
at the introitus, with the vagina being red,
erythematous on fire, she says.
A KOH prep of the vaginal secretions,
you see budding yeast and hyphae.
Now, which of the following will be the most appropriate?
Terconazole vaginally, fluconazole orally,
miconazole vaginally, clotrimazole vaginally.
Yeah, we're gonna use fluconazole twice, 72 hours apart,
because if you look at vaginal levels,
it remains high for 72 hours.
So we've got complicated vulva vaginal candidiasis there.
Those are pretty severe symptoms.
Dr. Weismiller is on fire.
These tend to be nonalbican species
as opposed to uncomplicated, infrequent,
mild to moderate candida.
These patients are immunocompetent, they're non-pregnant.
The biggest issues associated with vulvovaginal candidiasis,
the best evidence is poorly controlled diabetes,
immunosuppression, and HIV.
Now the nonalbican species like glabrata, et cetera,
those are the ones that tend to predominate here.
And it may be because,
you know, I use just a few days of the over the counter,
so I've kind of selected out for them.
How do we treat this?
Well, all the agents topically are highly effective.
Oral fluconazole is typically preferred, though.
It gets kind of unkempt and messy
when I gotta use this stuff every day
and I got all this discharge going on simultaneously.
So you can use a dose, 150 milligrams, then 72 hours later,
I do a second dose.
Or typically 14 days of a topical azole.
If you've got extensive vulvar erythema, edema, excoriation,
they may need a topical prep for a bit,
or a very low dose topical hydrocortisone cream,
so it doesn't penetrate quite as much.
Now what about recurrent?
I've got four episodes in 12 months,
or I've got three episodes,
unrelated to any antibiotics in 12 months.
This is a difficult area to treat.
We use induction therapy, so we give fluconazole,
three tablets now, one every 72 hours,
or 14 days of tropical treatment,
and then you put them on fluconazole once a week
for six months.
Long-term cure is still very challenging.
HSV.
Routine serologic screening, as we said,
not, not, not appropriate.
Latex condoms, they're effective in preventing transmission.
However, upwards of 40% of discordant couples
do not use them.
Remember, even if there's no lesion,
you don't know if they're now in exposing others to virus,
because we do not know about transmission there.
Primary HSV, no antibodies.
Typically this is not what we're seeing,
we're typically seeing the first clinical episode.
Both of them get treated typically 10 days.
If it's not completely healed after 10 days,
we can do a second 10 days.
If this is the primary or first episode,
typically 90% will have another one in the next 12 months.
Episodic, typically anywhere from one to five days,
depending on the antiviral you choose
is effective for treatment.
Suppressive therapy;
The CDC says if you have more than six outbreaks a year,
okay, I don't have any patient who says,
oh yeah, let me wait until I get to seven outbreaks,
then you can talk about suppression.
No.
We don't know if it reduces the subclinical viral shedding.
So you have to be very careful there
in terms of transmission.
Okay, here's our next AES question.
22-year-old sexually active female,
she comes to the office for a Pap test and STI screening.
Pap test is normal, but she tests positive for gonorrhea.
Chlamydia testing is negative.
Which of the following is the recommended treatment?
Doxy, ceftriaxone, ceftriaxone, or ceftriaxone?
Okay, it is ceftriaxone 500 milligrams, IM single dose.
Here is gonorrhea in the US, who's from Mississippi?
(audience laughing)
They're number one in the country for gonorrhea, number one.
You can see down there, the state is solid blue.
Okay.
You can see in the county where I live,
Southern Nevada, solid blue.
Okay, now, this is the recommendation from 2020.
Uncomplicated gonococcal, cervix, urethra, rectum,
500 milligrams.
If they're over 300 pounds, one gram.
No chlamydia infection, no doxy.
Chlamydia, they get doxy also,
or if they're pregnant, azithro.
Now, what about I don't have a ceftriaxone in Dr. W?
Then we can give Gent, plus azithro or Cefixime.
Now, what about pharyngeal gonorrhea?
I will disclose,
at a meeting similar to this in the past couple years,
here was the question.
Now Dr. Weismiller,
how would a someone get a pharyngeal gonorrhea?
(audience laughing)
There are no dumb questions, but that bordered.
Who was that? (laughing)
Okay, here, there's no reliable alternative
for pharyngeal gonorrhea.
If you have a test question
where they are beta-lactam allergic,
you gotta send them on typically to ID, okay?
Now what does all this mean then?
You need to be in clinical practice.
You need to be in clinical practice asking the question now,
where are you engaging with sex?
Because you need to screen multiple orifices potentially.
So typically what I'm doing is I'm getting urine specimen
and you wanna first void, okay?
And you only need a little bit.
Well, I don't know if it's a STI or a UTI,
we're gonna get two specimens then, a first void,
and then we'll stop, we'll do a cleansing,
and then we'll get a second midstream, okay?
But if you've had anaphylaxis or severe reaction,
you're like, okay, I cannot give them this drug,
then they gotta go to CID.
That's the recommendation, okay?
If it's pharyngeal.
Now test for reinfection here.
Why do we need tests for reinfection?
Because people tend to go back to the same people again.
You need 12 weeks after they've been treated,
test for reinfection.
12 weeks after treatment.
Now, unlike Trichomoniasis where it's just data for women,
here, it's men and women.
You do not need a test of cure, it works.
You're looking at a test for reinfection.
Okay, gonorrhea, here's who we screen.
15 to 24, they're at the highest infection rate.
Remember, sexual activity starts at age 12,
by 18, 50% of adolescents are sexually active.
25 years or older, if they're at a high risk group.
Previous or coexisting STI, newer more than one sex partner.
Some of you are thinking, oh, okay.
Here's our next question.
21-year-old had a pelvic examination
and normal Pap test a week ago.
Her screening test for chlamydia returned positive,
she's now being treated for chlamydia cervicitis.
When should she have a test for cure?
One to two weeks, two to four months, 12 months,
no test for cure required.
Okay, no test of cure.
Here's chlamydia.
Anybody visiting from Alaska?
They are number one for chlamydia.
Number one for chlamydia is Alaska.
Now here, there's one group of women
who does get a test of cure.
That is, if you're pregnant with chlamydia.
You get a test of cure three to four weeks later.
Everybody gets a test for reinfection.
Now, I know somebody's gonna ask me,
what do you mean test for cure, test for reinfection?
Just think about that, okay?
Very high rates of going back to the same person again.
So men and women who have been treated for chlamydia
should be retested three months later
as a test for reinfection.
Same high risk groups as for gonorrhea.
These are the areas where we need to screen.
We can do an endocervical or urine sample,
a urethral or urine sample
in females and males respectively.
An anal rectal swab that can be self collected,
and then a throat swab.
And so you have to have a discussion with patients.
So they come in and here's the, don't forget this,
remember, somebody comes in and says, oh, I need to be,
I'm here for STI testing, what's always the first question?
Have you been informed that a partner had STI?
Okay, very important because they need to be treated
regardless of what the testing shows.
And then I have to have a discussion.
Where do we need to swab?
You have to ask.
Okay, chlamydia, doxy.
Alternatively, Azithro or Levo.
Pregnancy, azithro or amox.
Okay, so high rates of reinfection, here's the summary.
Expedited partner therapy, Eba, look at me.
Please do not write a question about are you sure of this,
what if?
Don't write any of those questions.
Every state allows Expedited Partner Therapy.
This is particularly helpful for the treatment
of male partners of women
with chlamydial infection or gonorrhea.
Meaning, hello Priscilla,
Dr. Weismiller, it's one of three people,
I don't know their names, but I know where they are.
You can write a script to EPT,
Expedited Partner Therapy, that's the name on the script.
She gives it to the person, or you can call it in.
I need to call in a prescription, pharmacist.
Who's the patient?
EPT.
Then they go pick up the prescription.
Now, don't be doubling up the female's prescription.
That is fraud, okay?
Every state you can write to EPT.
The CDC says, please do this.
South Carolina was the last holdout,
you can now do it in that state.
If you know their name,
you just write a prescription to them.
Now, why do I say write?
Because if they're not in your EMR,
you just write the prescription or you call it in.
Don't be thinking anything else.
You don't have to worry about anything else,
that's all you have to do.
Write the prescription.
Well, Dr. Weismiller, supposed say they're allergic, you-
Doesn't matter, the data all shows it's safe, okay?
Okay, pelvic inflammatory disease.
If I don't treat it, this is what's gonna happen.
This is a clinical diagnosis,
uterine or adnexal tenderness,
or cervical motion tenderness, and no other cause,
start the therapy.
Now, if they have mucopurulrent discharge,
if they got an elevated SED rate, fine,
that's just added information, but you just started.
Why?
Increases their risk for ectopic and infertility
if you delay treatment.
Treat the sexual partner.
Any STI, you wanna treat any sexual partner
within the last 60 days.
In Clark County, we use 90 days now.
Okay, that's where I live.
Here are the treatments for outpatient IM oral treatment.
Ceftriaxone, cefoxitin,
or some other third generation cephalosporin.
Who gets admitted?
Well, I'm not sure, is this appendicitis or PID?
Man, they look sick.
Gosh, I started them 72 hours ago and they look worse now.
Dr. Weismiller, I can't get back here in 72 hours.
Okay, those all need to be admitted.
Here's what we do when we use
parental treatment in the hospital.
Okay, HIV, everybody gets screened regardless of risk level.
It's a level A recommendation,
which means your insurance has to cover it at least once.
Have you ever been screened for HIV?
Yeah, it was negative.
Do you need to be re-screened?
No.
Okay, fine.
High certainty that this is most appropriate.
15 to 65 at least once.
If they engage in high risk sexual behaviors,
probably screening on an annual basis at a minimum.
We now use a fourth generation screening cascade testing.
So we're looking for antibody and antigen.
Now, the onus is on us to prescribe PrEP.
And in my clinical experience,
patients don't come in saying, I think I need to be on PrEP.
90% of the time I'm saying, do you think you need to be on
pre-exposure prophylaxis for HIV?
And they're like, oh yeah, that'd be a good idea, okay?
So it recommends that clinicians offer PrEP,
anyone who's at risk for acquisition of HIV.
Now, here is what the USPSTF says with the high risk groups.
Men who have sex with men, or sexually active
and have one of the following characteristics.
Serodiscordant sex partner, there's an asterisk there.
Because if you are in a monogamous relationship
with an HIV positive individual
who is completely virally suppressed,
the recommendation is that the HIV negative individual
not go on therapy.
Because if you are undetectable, it's untransmittable.
Well, if it's untransmittable,
why am I gonna go on a drug then
that potentially increases my risk of a problematic issue,
you know, 'cause any drug could?
Heterosexually active women and men
who have one of the following characteristics.
Serodiscordant, inconsistent use of condoms, STI.
I had a patient recently come to my practice, 63 years old.
Here's the, here was the, I'm like,
why do you need a new doctor?
Nobody will talk about, nobody, meaning physician,
will talk about sex with me.
And she is a woman who in her postmenopausal era
has been more empowered to be sexually active,
and has multiple sexual partners now, and she said,
I would benefit from being on PrEP.
So we talked about sex, and I started her on PrEP.
Persons who inject drugs
and have one of the following characteristics.
Now, there are three FDA approved medications.
Two are oral, one is an injection.
They're only not recommended
if your creatinine clearance is less than 30.
Now here's the minimum baseline testing, this is new.
You have to do both an HIV antigen/antibody
and an HIV-1 RNA.
You need to look for Hepatitis B.
We now recommend what's called a triple panel test
in screening anyone for Hep B.
So they get an Hepatitis B service antigen,
and anti hepatitis B service antigen,
and a total hepatitis B core antigen.
That is what is recommended.
Most of your labs are routinely doing this in terms of a
triple panel test or cascade.
And then you need a creatinine.
You wanna make sure that creatinine clearance
is greater than 30.
Now here's the monitoring if you're on
either of the forms of daily oral PrEP.
I'm gonna leave that to you to review,
but you can see it's changed a bit.
In terms of when you need this,
all patients will need a renal function at least every year.
But if you start with a creatinine clearance of less than 90
or you are more mature,
you need to have that every six months.
And then that is the recommendation in terms of frequency
of bacterial STI screening.
Men who have sex with men, and transgender women
who have sex with men every three months.
Okay, now here is the monitoring if you're on the injection.
So you get the testing, you get two injections
within the first two months.
And then after the second injection, it's every two months.
Every two months.
You can see there
that you would get an HIV antigen/antibody test
every four months, and you will, or excuse me,
every two months, and you follow up every four months
beginning with injection number three,
which is the third month,
you would get bacterial STI screening.
Time to effectiveness.
Typically for receptive anal sex, seven days,
receptive vaginal sex, and injection drug use 20 days.
We don't know about insertive anal or of vaginal.
When you're stopping it,
you should at least continue it for four weeks
after the last significant exposure.
Here's the effectiveness of PrEP, basically 99%.
If you inject drugs, it reduces it probably by 74%.
I mean, you think about, did you ever think
for those of you who trained when I did
in the late 80s, and you know,
when these people were dying right and left,
that HIV would be just a chronic,
I say just a chronic disease,
I had a patient come back to me recently
after I told him he was positive.
We had a long discussion about it and he said to me,
you could have given me a lot worse diagnoses.
That's incredible to think about when you know,
when you think from where we came
with this particular disease.
And just as a historical piece, real quick.
So I'm finishing up my undergraduate degree, and I have two.
One is in music, and one is in microbiology.
So I needed a senior thesis project at microbiology.
So my senior thesis project is on Coronaviruses.
And I spent five years
working in a coronavirus lab after that.
And, so who would've ever thought?
But I'm finishing up my senior thesis project, fall of 1984.
And my mentor, Kay Holmes,
who's one of the leading coronaviruses coronavirologists,
not only in the country, but actually in the world.
She's at the University of Denver,
or University of Colorado, Denver now.
She said, Hey David, Bob Gallo's coming over from NIH.
Okay, Bob Gallo's coming over, how's Bob?
She says, yeah, he's gonna be talking about HTLV.
And at the end he may talk about this new virus
they think they have found, called HTLV3.
Okay, there we were, five minutes, Bob talked about HTLV3.
Fast forward a few months and whew,
everything went down from there.
Okay, how to introduce this topic to people.
Here is what I would recommend.
Are you interested in hearing
about medications that can prevent HIV?
Have you heard of PrEP?
How do you think your sex life would improve
if you didn't have to worry about HIV?
Those are three that I use.
Non-occupational post-exposure prophylaxis.
Now, occupational post-exposure prophylaxis,
your healthcare systems have detailed protocols for that.
This is the person who comes in and says, oops,
I should have probably used some protection.
You want to initiate non-occupational
post-exposure prophylaxis within 72 hours,
that's gonna be really important.
It's a 28 day course of a three drug antiretroviral regimen.
You repeat the testing at four to six weeks,
and then three months.
Oral tests, they are not recommended here.
If you have an HCV antibody test,
which is negative baseline,
but positive at four to six weeks after the exposure,
you should do an HIV antibody test at three and six months,
because you wanna rule out a delayed HIV seroconversion.
Okay, coming down the end of this,
according to the CDC screening for syphilis
should be undertaken by which of the following?
Dark-field, nontreponemal serology,
fluorescent treponemal antibody absorption test,
or the Weil-Felix test?
Okay, so I'm gonna modify this question because it actually,
the answer could be B or C now,
the CDC has recently changed this.
So it could be B or C.
So general ulcers, we're thinking herpes
and we're thinking about specific tests for Treponemia,
HSV, Hemophilus ducreyi, and HIV testing.
We biopsied a woman last week
because she had these three ulcers on her vulva,
to which the orthopedic surgeon she was seeing,
because she has two broken hips, referred her to GYN.
And I asked the daughter, I'm like,
did the orthopedic surgeon take a look at her vulva?
She said, oh no.
I'm like, okay.
But I'm like, we biopsied it, 'cause it was,
she's got three big ulcers there.
If it doesn't respond to therapy
and you think it's infectious,
you gotta worry about vulvar intraepithelial neoplasia.
Now here's syphilis, of course, Nevada's number one.
Now here's the only sadder thing.
My hometown D.C, if you made us a state,
we'd be number one for all three.
It's a huge issue right now in terms of Washington D.C.
Okay, so when we diagnose this,
the CDC recognizes both the traditional
and reverse algorithm can now be used.
Now, if we think about who gets screened,
if you're at increased risk, men who have sex with men,
men and women living with HIV or other STI,
history of incarceration, commercial sex work,
any domicile type living.
Now, here is the traditional algorithm.
I use a non strep, a non treponemal test first.
However, what you can see here is,
these tend to be operator dependent,
false negatives can be very high in early primary syphilis.
And the false positives can be anywhere from 2% to 5%,
particularly acute febrile illness,
pregnancy autoimmune disease.
So the reverse sequence
is where I start with treponemal serology.
If that's reactive, they go onto a quantitative RPR.
If that is negative, they go onto a treponemal direct test.
If that is negative, syphilis, that's unlikely,
if it's positive, they get treated, okay?
So this is where most people are now.
If you go to our hospital and order an RPR,
you can't do it now.
It's all going to be starting with
that treponemal serologic test.
Either an enzyme, some type of enzyme linked assay.
The advantages here.
Sensitive automated, it improves your clinical detection,
and the workflow is much more enhanced, studies have shown.
That's the advantages of that reverse algorithm.
So that's just for your summary.
Okay, in terms of treatment,
penicillin, penicillin, penicillin.
If you can't take penicillin, you desensitize them.
We have some limited data on doxy and tetracycline.
Azithro potentially.
Keep in mind Jarisch-Herxheimer again,
because you're gonna have that reported to you.
And our last AES question, a 35-year-old man
sees you in the office to establish care.
You learn his parents were born in Southeast Asia.
He was born in the US,
he does not have any vaccination records.
During the visit, he mentions that a relative
was recently diagnosed with Hep B.
He asked whether he should be screened.
According to the USPS, screen, 'cause he's at high risk.
Do not screen, but provide the first dose of the vaccine.
Don't screen because he was born in the US,
or screen, he's at high risk of developing
a chronic infection,
which could go on to cirrhosis or malignancy.
Okay, A is the correct answer here.
We've got, we're all over the board there,
but A is the correct answer, you wanna screen.
Okay, so the USPSTF recommends screening
all pregnant women as Dr-
as we looked at earlier today,
Dr. Vesti reiterated that yesterday,
and those who are at high risk, including US-born citizens,
persons not vaccinated as infants,
and your parent was born in a high prevalence area,
particularly Sub-Saharan Africa, Southeast and East Asia.
Those are the big areas in terms of persistent infections.
Now, antiviral therapy reduces risk of mortality
and malignancy.
And even intermediate outcomes are improved.
We now vaccinate newborns,
not before they leave the hospital,
but within 24 hours of delivering.
That's how important this is.
Three dose, two dose can be used,
but you can't use it in pregnancy,
and the two dose can only be used in adults.
Now, we never revaccinate
in terms of more than twice with a Hepatitis B series.
So if the patient has to be determine their serology status
for whatever reason,
although the CDC does not recommend it routinely,
and you find that they are seronegative,
there's two ways to do this.
You can give them the first injection of the second series
and then test.
If they're IgG positive,
they just had a quiet immune system.
Or you can just say,
we're just gonna give you the whole series.
If they test negative after the second series, that's it,
you do not give them a third.
Okay, no more than two.
And then just a word on Hepatitis C,
which is not sexually transmitted.
Rare would be that.
But the current recommendation,
Hepatitis C kills more people in the US every year
than the other 60 communicable diseases combined.
4.1 million persons have passed their current HCV infection,
look at this.
2.4 million have current infections based on testing.
This is all within our ballpark, now, in terms of treatment,
they're all PO medications.
So the CDC is calling on us to be part of this.
It's transmitted through parenteral exposure.
Infrequent is transmitted through sex,
sharing contaminated infectious blood issues
such as razors, tattooing.
The recommendation, everybody between the 18 and 79
get screened at least once, you just do it.
The testing strategy is looking for current infection.
So we do an HCV antibody.
If that's reactive, it gets an HCV-RNA.
If it's detected, they do a repeat,
and if it's detected again, you get treated.
But you can do the treatment.
Here are our practice recommendations as we look at STIs,
and we are done.
Thank you very much.
(audience clapping)
(signature chime)